como un déjà vú han pasado más de 80
años desde el holocausto judío pero sus
supervivientes en ucrania sienten ahora
la guerra como un horror ya ha vivido
de quien odiamos entonces bueno había
una guerra los alemanes atacaban y
nosotros subíamos del frente y amos de
la guerra
en las últimas semanas sólo unos 50 de
los 10.000 judíos en ucrania han sido
evacuados en huída de nuevo de un
conflicto del que no son protagonistas
la mayoría de ellos ha llegado a
alemania el país europeo que en la
actualidad acoge al 80% de la población
judía del 'viejo continente' atraída por
las atractivas políticas que impulsaron
para expiar su turbulento pasado para la
comunidad judía alemana es una
obligación no dejarlos atrás en este
difícil momento
está claro que los supervivientes del
holocausto lo que están viviendo ahora
les recuerda cómo y que vivieron antes
cuando eran niños de nosotros la
conferencia de reclamaciones sentimos la
profunda obligación de no abandonar a
los supervivientes del holocausto esta
bestia
cerca de 500 supervivientes ucranianos
del holocausto son especialmente
vulnerables por su delicado estado de
salud su evacuación progresiva es
esencial y los que ya llegaron se
sienten agradecidos por esta nueva
oportunidad de vida
entiendo que si hay un monstruo como
putin a la cabeza del estado el pueblo
es inocente y la forma en la que nos
reciben ahora siento un gran
agradecimiento y una inmensa gratitud
nos algunos lograron salir pero no todos
los supervivientes del holocausto en
ucrania tuvieron la misma suerte en el
terreno donde los bombardeos de las
tropas rusas también atacaron los
símbolos de un episodio de la historia
que hoy revive en muchos ellos